[Musique]
beaucoup de monde ce matin devant le
magasin d'un radio électricien c'est toi
monsieur wauquiez
tout cela pour regarder la télévision
mais pas une émission habituel une
émission en couleur et à ce sujet nous
regrettons de ne pas pouvoir traduire
tout l'intérêt de cette nouveauté est
temps pour notre part et pour l'instant
cantonnée dans le noir et blanc
monsieur wauquiez a toujours été
d'ailleurs un précurseur car il y à
présent autant de personnes étaient
réunies devant sa vitrine pour une autre
grande première
oui et 7 à 1954 c'était à ce moment là
pour présenter la télévision en noir et
blanc
aujourd'hui c'est autre chose c'est de
la télévision oui c'est la première fois
qu'on présente ses toiles je pense le
posséder ces câbles et ceci grâce à ce
récepteur que vous avez réalisé avec un
peu les moyens du bord si j'ose dire oui
on peut on peut le constater soi-même à
voyez vous un troupeau de la cornière
ont perforé on trouve un peu toutes
sortes de change la rédac et cette année
ça me va a pu le faire un téléviseur
il y à des pièces détachées à récupérer
sur de vieux porc noir et blanc
transformer évidemment il ya aussi des
composants nécessaires à la couleur et
avec beaucoup de travail et j'ai pu
faire ce que vous voyez
pensez vous qu'un radio électricien
éclairé enfin un amateur éclairé même
puisse arriver au même résultat que oui
c'est certain mais à condition qu'ils
soient déjà occupé real a un très bonne
technicienne en noir et blanc pourrait
certainement faire à la même chose
quoique j'avoue qu'il y avait du travail
j'ai travaillé beaucoup de mises au
point délicate à réaliser
je ne vous demanderai pas d'entrer dans
les détails évidemment parce que ce
serait un peu difficile mais la théorie
de la réception couleurs en gros comment
peut-elle se résumer en ce qui concerne
je vous avais dit le mot réception il
n'y a pas deux il ya peu de différence
avec le noir et blanc paraît ce qui
concerne la réception et de même c'est
pour recomposer les couleurs que ce que
la difficulté est là il faut évidemment
une super spéciale un cube krom ce tube
est formé d'une couche plus aux récentes
qui est composé de
point de phosphore de trois couleurs
différentes le rouge le bleu et le vert
par les faisceaux d'électrons qui les
impressionne chez point luminescents
sont plus ou moins impressionné les
jeunes les autres et par le mélange de
ces trois couleurs on arrive à les faire
toute une dernière question combien de
temps avez vous mis pour construire
cette place
j'ai mis environ un mois et demi en
faisant ça en dehors de mon travail j'ai
souvent pensé parce que l'avion s'est
couché à 3 heures du matin de lui à brac
naturellement pour les radios
électricien pour les confrères de
monsieur wauquiez c'est de l'autre côté
de l'écran que réside une grande partie
de l'intérêt mais qu'en pense le
téléspectateur
[Musique]